[Musica]
quando rivedo le foto del 2014 in cui
avevo 23 anni mi viene un enorme voglia
di abbracciarmi
È incredibile come riusciamo sempre a
essere così Severi con noi stessi ma
quando poi ci troviamo a guardare al
passato riusciamo finalmente a guardarci
con occhi diversi
a essere più indulgenti ad avere un modo
di affetto nei nostri confronti
O almeno per me è così
le foto di quel periodo sono quasi tutte
foto fatte allo specchio
lo specchio quello strumento che era
diventato una tortura insieme alla
bilancia Se ne stavano lì nel loro
angolino nella stanza mi guardavano con
fare sinistro aspettando solo che io mi
avvicinassi per aggredirmi per farmi a
pezzi
a ben vedere però non erano loro a farmi
a pezzi
ero io stessa
mi mettevo davanti allo specchio e mi
scrutavo alla ricerca di ogni possibile
difetto in base all'immagine che vedevo
la giornata partiva bene oppure male
ero diventata schiava dei Body check
è una terminologia che ho imparato
successivamente quando sono finalmente
riuscita a dare un nome alle cose perché
si è parlato molto di più di tanti
argomenti sensibili
se è vero che dare un nome a un certo
comportamento può sembrare una cosa
delimitata rilevanza è anche vero che
sapere che questa cosa esiste che quindi
altre persone hanno vissuto la stessa
esperienza
aiuta molto
i vari check consistono in un controllo
ossessivo della propria immagine al fine
di verificarne i cambiamenti attraverso
lo specchio la bilancia misurandone i
centimetri confrontandosi con se stessi
oppure con altre persone
è un comportamento tipico di chi soffre
disturbi alimentari diventa quasi un
rituale
ogni mattina mi svegliavo Mi alzavo mi
mettevo davanti allo specchio e mi
scrutavo
a volte scattavo anche delle foto per
alimentare ulteriormente quella
ossessione nei confronti della mia
immagine vedere la pancia piatta sentire
le costole mi dava qualche senso di
tranquillità
era diventata un'abitudine di cui
neanche mi accorgevo più Ogni volta che
passavo davanti a uno specchio ed ero da
sola perché mai avrei usato di fronte ad
altre persone in fondo Sapevo che
qualcosa non andava dicevo ogni volta
che passavo davanti allo specchio quello
che facevo era tirarmi su una maglia e
controllarmi
succedeva Soprattutto dopo aver mangiato
come se avessi paura che quel cibo si
potesse depositare immediatamente dove
meno lo desideravo
se l'immagine che lo specchio mi
restituiva mi piaceva
andava tutto bene
Se invece non mi piaceva mi dicevo che
facevo schifo
Sì schifo Faccio quasi fatica a dirlo
adesso
per tanti anni mi sono parlata con
disprezzo senza che neanche nessuno lo
potesse immaginare o lo potesse sapere
spesso da fuori
Tutto sembra normale
la dismorfobia è un mostriciattolo
dispettoso non riesci a guardare il tuo
corpo per quello che è ti sembra di
avere dei difetti enormi Anche se le
altre persone da fuori neanche
noterebbero quello che tu ritieni
orrendo Se soffri di sborranofobia non
riesce a guardare il tuo corpo con
obiettività tutto ti sembra troppo o
troppo poco e il tuo corpo diventa
motivo di ansia e preoccupazione
costanti
quando avevo deciso che dovevo uscire da
questo loop che tutto questo non doveva
essere normale che il mio rapporto con
il cibo poteva essere migliore che
volevo fare pace con il mio corpo
ero aumentata di peso Come spesso accade
una delle preoccupazioni più grandi di
chi soffre disturbi alimentari
è proprio quella di ritrovarsi con un
corpo ben diverso da quello che
inizialmente si desiderava
Se però si vuole davvero
guarire a mio avviso una cosa
fondamentale è riuscire a spostare il
focus
se si continua a desiderare di avere un
certo peso un certo corpo non si
riuscirà mai a combattere certi demoni
fino in fondo
a un certo punto ci si deve chiedere Che
cos'è più importante la mia salute
o avere il fisico dei miei sogni
e la risposta purtroppo
non è così scontata
credo che sia proprio questa
consapevolezza
ad avermi consentito di cambiare
atteggiamento nei miei confronti Perché
per troppo tempo mi sono guardata
disprezzando la mia immagine
un giorno poi
Mi sono detta basta
Basta non ti permetterà mai più di
parlare a te stessa in questo modo
quella promessa silenziosa ha fatto
davvero la differenza il mio rapporto
con me stessa Certo non è stato
immediato come per tutto è stato un
percorso lungo lento tortuoso più volte
mi capitava di sentir riaffiorare Certi
pensieri ma a quel punto mi fermavo
facevo chiarezza nella mia mente e vi
dicevo No
hai promesso a te stessa che non ti
saresti ma vi parlata così
e quella che all'inizio altro non era se
non un'imposizione è diventata
un'abitudine
sembra una cosa da nulla ma il modo in
cui ci rivolgiamo noi stessi o fare
tutta la differenza del mondo
invece di guardarci cercando le cose che
di noi non sopportiamo dovrebbe provare
a guardarci cercando qualcosa
di positivo da dire a noi stessi
un passo ulteriore e per nulla semplice
da fare sarebbe poi riuscire a capire
che la nostra immagine non ci
rappresenta come persone
se In un primo momento può essere utile
attraversare lo specchio per
abbracciarci senza giudizi e anche vero
che dobbiamo capire che il nostro corpo
non ha nulla a che vedere con il nostro
valore comprendere che il nostro corpo è
estremamente utile ogni giorno ma che
non ci definisce come persone che siamo
molto più del nostro corpo
è per questo che a bordo quella retorica
estremamente diffusa Soprattutto negli
ultimi anni che ci invita a dimagrire
per amarci di più
la risposta a un nostro disagio
interiore che ci porta a non apprezzarci
non può essere cambiare il nostro
aspetto esteriore
nel mio periodo più buio in cui avevo
raggiunto un peso terribilmente basso
non avevo imparato niente non mi amavo
di più non mi apprezzavo di più certo
provavo una certa soddisfazione
nell'entrare in ogni negozio e sapere
che la mia taglia sarebbe sicuramente
stata quella più piccola ma questo solo
perché viviamo in una società che ci
dice che è magro è meglio e per via
della mia gastrofobia interiorizzata di
cui ai tempi non avevo la minima
cognizione
dimagrire non è sempre sano Perché può
succedere per moltissimi fattori un
lutto una malattia appunto un disturbo
alimentare e non è detto tra l'altro che
il peso che una persona desidera
raggiungere sia il peso più sano per
quella persona non è dimagrendo che si
impara a rispettare il proprio corpo è
qualcosa che deve venire
indipendentemente dal nostro aspetto
perché non è l'aspetto a definirci è
qualcosa che deve venire da dentro della
nostra mente se riusciamo ad apprezzarci
solo se abbiamo un determinato aspetto
c'è qualcosa che non quadra
un amore più grande per il nostro corpo
non è cercare di plasmarlo al fine di
assomigliare il più possibile all'ideale
della società è riuscire ad apprezzarlo
per quello che ci consente di fare ogni
giorno
diamo per scontate così tante cose ma il
nostro corpo ci consente di ridere
scherzare parlare di fronte a una platea
di persone ci consente di sognare
viaggiare abbracciare le persone che
amiamo
non importa quanto male lo possiamo aver
trattato il nostro corpo è sempre lì e
ci consente di fare cose straordinarie
ogni giorno
purtroppo
i messaggi che riceviamo
dicono l'esatto opposto del resto
viviamo in un mondo che ha
interiorizzato i concetti della Direct
culture
that culture è un altro termine che ho
imparato poi
è quell'insieme di credenze che vede il
cibo diviso come in buono e cattivo
l'allenamento come un mero mezzo per
bruciare le calorie e la forma fisica
come fine supremo a cui aspirare
in questo contesto le persone vengono
connotate moralmente in base a quanto
pesano in base alla taglia che indossano
in base a quanto si allenano a cosa
mangiano
una persona quindi con un corpo grasso
sarà una persona che è una pigra
indolenza una persona che mangia solo
Junk Food che non tiene a se stessa che
non si vuole bene la verità però
chiaramente è ben diversa ci possono
essere tantissimi motivi per cui una
persona prende peso e questo dice nulla
di lei come persona
quella contro i corpi Grassi purtroppo è
una vera e propria discriminazione ma
facciamo davvero fatica a riconoscerla
come tale quindi a combatterla proprio
perché siamo influenzati da tutti questi
concetti è necessario uno sforzo attivo
quindi per liberarcene
e dobbiamo capire che avere un certo
corpo non è né un vanto né una colpa
è una mera caratteristica che non dice
nulla di chi siamo nessuno un giorno
dirà era così una bella persona pesava
solo tot chili nessun amico Pensa di noi
o le voglio così bene Porta quella
taglia lì
siamo molto più della nostra immagine e
io ci ho messo tanti anni per capirlo ma
adesso finalmente
quando mi metto davanti allo specchio
riesco a vedere il mio corpo Per quello
che è
semplicemente
un corpo
ed è sicuramente vero che per me è molto
più facile parlare di altre persone
perché un corpo che viene accettato
dalla società Ma è anche vero che penso
che ci sia bisogno che tutti ci battiamo
affinché certi stereotipi vengano
superati e Affinché nessuno mai debba
sentirsi sbagliato per Come appare
Grazie